hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book 10 of his confessions saint
augustine is going to approach one of
the
classic problems of ancient philosophy
that runs through to the present for us
what is human happiness what will
make us happy what does happiness
consist in what does it require what is
it oriented by and given all the many
conceptions that people do have
of happiness which ones are
right and which ones are
off base
now he is going to frame this first in
terms of memory since this entire
book is concerned with these these
questions of this great capacity of
human beings and he's going to say we
have this this notion
of the happy life he says when i seek
you my god i seek the happy life let me
seek you so that my soul may live
my body lives by my soul my soul lives
by you so the body is less than the soul
the soul is orienting the body and the
soul is oriented towards something else
that is not already
entirely there within the soul although
the promise
of it certainly is
so he says
how then do i seek the happy life the
bayata vita right uh greeks called this
eudaimonia
you know or there was also the framework
of the happy life or the blessed life
right and this is the way that that
augustine is expressing it now he says
something really interesting
here
in terms of the orientation the affect
of orientation towards the happy life
that not everybody
necessarily
had the concept of
earlier philosophers would say things
like well everybody desires the happy
life augustine is going to say
every human being everybody
wills
coming from volare right
the voluntas is one of the central
faculties of the human being it's very
extensive in augustine not that people
didn't have a conception of this before
augustine but it's very very evident in
him so we all not only desire but one of
the modes of that desire or you might
say the desire fits in as a motive this
is willing
orienting ourselves
choosing
in some respect the happy life and he
says this is very interesting as a
follow-up in the very same line
no person nemo in latin entirely wills
against
the happy
life
omnino nolit knowlet is coming from nola
ray which is sort of the opposite of
volare right you will
for something you will to something you
can also will against something you can
say no i don't want that
what do i want i don't know but i don't
want that
right so there's nobody who entirely
rejects the happy life
and this is a very important
coupling together because you can say
well listen if everybody desires or
wills the happy life why aren't we all
happy right now and he said well
our wills are divided
we do in fact
want happiness sometimes we can be mixed
up about it
but you know there's other things going
on there we also will other
goods that are not going to make us
happy because we think they're going to
make us happy but they interfere with
genuine happiness there's a certain
perversity in our wills as well that
he's going to reference a little bit
later on the battle between the flesh
and the spirit
so
we'll get into that in a bit
and there's there's a couple different
modalities of this that he discusses he
says
so let's let's actually give a little
context here he says is not the happy
life that which all will to have no
intent no person entirely wills against
where have they known it that they in
such wise will to possess it where have
they seen it
so that they love it
truly we have it but how i do not know
right so
there's
modalities of
affection towards the happy life people
hope for it and augustine says
hoping for it is not bad right it's not
as good as actually having
or experiencing the happy life but it's
certainly better than not being
connected with a happy life at all
right he says there's a way in which a
man is happy when he has the happy life
and then there are those who are happy
because of hope this is happiness in a
lower way
than those who are already happy in fact
or in reality but it's better than those
who are happy neither in fact or in hope
so through hope we can be made
partially happy you could say right
loving it
having not just desire but actual love
for the happy life there's a lot of
different modalities of love and we
could go into that you can say well some
modalities just our desire i want that
thing i want to have it
but there's also like appreciation as
well
and then
does this mean that we
we know the happy life
i mean how can we
hope for it or love it how can we have
these affective orientations if we don't
already have some idea where those are
going a cognitive direction we have to
know the happy life don't we in order to
do that and
aren't we
remembering it in some way i mean we
remember all these
other things as it turns out and here
we get into a really interesting
examination how how do we remember the
happy life
so first augustine says
is this just like one who's seen the
city of carthage remembers it no why not
because the happy life is not seen by
the eyes it's not a body
it's not something that we take in
uh through
primarily sense impressions although it
could include sense impressions right we
could have memories of spending time
with our friends and family in harmony
and you know having good food and drink
and listening to music and it was a
beautiful summer day and there were
odors in the air
the breeze was caressing us all this
sort of stuff right
we could think back to all sorts of
other experiences and say well that was
what the happy life was like
yes but that's not the happy life itself
that's not what we're fundamentally
oriented towards so that's not the
memory of the happy life those are
better understood as being memories of
being happy or being joyful at a given
point in time
is it like the knowledge that we have
say he says in
numbers is it like the way we remember
numbers no
because one who holds them in knowledge
does not seek to acquire them
whereas we possess the happy life and
knowledge and therefore love it but
still
wish to obtain it so we be maybe
actually
happy
so you know uh you could say well let's
push this a little bit
let's say you really love
mathematics right you really love
working with it can't you say that
there's there's an aspect of
you know wanting to hold on to those
yes i i suppose you could say the
numbers you know remembering theorems
remembering relations between them
remembering what you learned back in
calculus or linear algebra or number
theory or stuff like that
yes but you don't possess it in the same
way that you possess happiness
so there's a different
modality here as well
well what about
the acts or arts of speech augustine
remember is a trained rhetorician he has
studied philosophy he studied grammar he
studied rhetoric he studied dialectic he
studied all these sorts of things he
remembers them he says that this is
different than like sense impressions
because i have the actual things these
arts these skills
within my mind within my memory
is that
how we remember the happy life he says
no
because even those who are not skilled
speakers recall the thing itself when
they hear the word and many people
desire to be eloquent
so it's apparent that this is in their
knowledge
but by means of their bodily senses
they've taken note of other people who
are finished speakers have been pleased
by them desire to be such themselves and
he says they would not have been pleased
unless because of some inner knowledge
nor would they have wanted to be
eloquent unless they'd been pleased
whereas we
do not perceive the happy life in others
by means of any bodily sense
and this actually raises a really
interesting question
well
do we perceive the happy life in others
in those that you know perhaps we hear
about you know um
augustine himself telling us these
stories stories within these stories
or
do we perceive it in their lives people
who we live with and then we say i want
what that person
has if not
then maybe we can't perceive the happy
life in anybody
except ourselves
but that doesn't make sense i mean if
that was the case wouldn't it be kind of
a non-starter to say sweeping statements
like the happy life is what all people
will
can we directly observe the volitions of
other people this is something that
augustine doesn't
completely clarify at this point instead
he goes on and he suggests another line
of thinking
is it like
the way that we
remember joy
what is it like
to remember joy he says
maybe this is the case even when i'm sad
i remember my joys just as when wretched
i remember the happy life
but i never saw or heard or smelled or
tasted her to touch joy by a bodily
sense
i have experienced it in my mind when i
have rejoiced and knowledge of it has
clung to my
memory and i can remember it sometimes
with disgust
not all joy is necessarily good you know
think about the joy and picking on some
poor kid in gym class back when you're
in middle school and kind of a miserable
brat and you know you you took some
satisfaction in joining in the club oh
you should actually be ashamed of
yourself in that case right
you don't have to just steal pairs to do
bad things
so he says sometimes with disgust
sometimes with desire sometimes you
remember a past joy and you're like
oh that was good like you think about a
really great meal or
a wonderful you know musical experience
or you know a great romantic interlude
or something like that
and you'd be like oh i want more
of that sort of thing even if you're not
going to have it and he he goes on and
he says
um
you know
it depends on what we're thinking of
i've been plunged into a sort of joy
from all sorts of things
and with you know sometimes the sadness
i recall past joy but let's go back to
the happy life so he says where then and
when did i have experience with a happy
life so i can remember it
and love it and long for it it's not
merely myself with a few others but all
of us all human beings he reasserts
without exception
want to be happy unless we
knew this with sure knowledge some kind
of knowledge we
wouldn't want it with such a sure will a
will that we can depend on in ourselves
and in others
and then he makes a really important
distinction here
says look everyone wants to be happy and
experience joy
not everybody
gets it the same way not everybody's
joys are the same not everybody
conceptualizes
the happy life in the same
manner and he's got this great example
of of two people who you ask hey you
want to be a soldier now being a soldier
in the ancient world uh had certain
perks that came with it and a lot of
other things that were uh real obstacles
to happiness you know you'd have to
especially a roman soldier you'd be
marching a lot and
you know having to put up with
discipline and so you ask people do you
want to be a soldier and some of them
will be like yeah man that's what i want
and others will be like
you got to be crazy there's no way i
want to be a soldier and augustine says
both of them give these responses why
because they want to be happy
one person conceives of the soldiering
life as a means to happiness or as the
happy life
another may
say no no no i need to do something
completely different and i definitely
don't want that i do want to be happy
that's just not what the happy life is
going to be
so he says all people agree that they
want to be happy
just as they would agree if they're
asked that they want to be joyful in
this very joy they call the happy life
so one seeks it in one way the other in
a different way there is one thing they
all strive to attain that is to have joy
so then the question
what is this
and augustine at this point in his life
and aunt book 10 in the confessions can
give the best answer in his view an
answer that not everybody is going to
accept so what is true happiness well he
tells us that it is god it's not the
soul
it's not you know uh
total independence
it's not
having every knowledge at your disposal
or any of these other things it's the
human being in relation to god so he
says
that um
there's a joy that's not granted to the
wicked but only those who worship you
and now notice this this cuts out any
sort of like transactional oh i want
happiness therefore i'm going to worship
god because god's going to give me that
happiness he says those who worship you
for your own
sake
not for the sake of
being happy but for the sake of being
connected with what is most truthful
greatest all that which will make you
happy right but if you're trying to get
the happiness directly like you know a
commodity that you bargained for you're
not going to get it so he says
for whom you yourself are joy
this is the happy life to rejoice over
you
to you
and because of you this is it and there
is no other those who think that there
is another such life pursue another joy
and it's not true joy it
has some
connection to joy it's not totally
disconnected but it's not the real deal
so he says their will is not turned away
from a certain image
of joy that everybody has within them
some sort of
basic fundamental
inerraticable orientation towards
god they just don't understand it and in
the next chapter he talks about truth
and he says that what is
genuine happiness what is that we're
actually looking for
it says i ask everybody whether they
would rather have joy and truth or in
falsity they no more hesitate to say
they prefer to have joy in the truth
then they hesitate to say they desire to
be happy in fact
for augustine he goes on
joy in the truth
is
the happy
life
so
this is a really important formula
this doesn't just mean truthful joy joy
also in the truth
taking joy in truth and now this gets us
to back to this this point right well
how can somebody
not want this
how can they want something else instead
and this is the chapter where augustine
tells us a couple very useful things
he says
it's clear everybody desires to be happy
but
why don't they desire to have joy in you
which is the only happy life
he says well
there's this biblical quote that really
helps us out here the flesh lusts
against the spirit and the spirit
against the flesh so they do not do what
they wish they fall down to what they're
able to take and they're satisfied with
that this is a really basic idea of
augustinian moral philosophy that you
know we we have to
want desire will something we love
something he often frames us in terms of
love and if we're not orienting ourself
to the highest good that is god
and arranging everything else in
relation to god which is going to mean
you know sacrificing some genuine goods
which are lesser goods like you know
taking pleasure in whatever we want
right or taking revenge on enemies
if we um
[Music]
decide not to and we pursue those things
and we leave out the highest good then
we've got a contradiction within our
will we're messed up inside we have
conflicts and this is going to generate
not just sort of action conflicts or
volitional conflicts but also affective
conflicts and also cognitive conflicts
we're going to get things wrong
in a
number of different ways we're going to
have a mistaken set of priorities right
and so this can be framed in terms of
the spirit and the flesh and the divided
will
he also goes on and he talks about this
in terms of truth and he says listen
i've known a lot of people who want to
deceive other people
none of them want to be deceived and so
they really do want the truth they want
the truth sort of in the wrong
ways right and he says here's an
important question why then is it that
the truth begets hatred
why is your man who preaches truth to
men become an enemy in their eyes even
though there is love for the happy life
well it's because they're messed up he
says
truth is loved in such a way that that
people who love some other object want
what they love to be the truth
and because they don't want to be
deceived they refuse to be convinced
that they have been deceived i mean it's
really interesting to think about this
when people have been
conned right when they've been taken in
deceived by other people
one of the last things that they want to
admit is that they they have been taken
advantage of they have been lied to
they've been conned and when they do it
to themselves
they're both the con man
and the mark right and they lie to
themselves about what's actually
happening
what it is that they've committed
themselves to they say that you know
pleasure is the only good or they say
that um you know virtue is the only good
and they leave god out of the picture
because god
would expect something different taking
account of god would require them to
re-prioritize and so he says again
there's a conflict right
they hate the truth for the sake of that
very thing which they have loved instead
of the truth
they love the truth
because it brings light to them
they hate the truth because it reproves
them
because they don't want to be deceived
but wish to deceive they love it when it
shows itself to them and they hate it
when it shows
them
to themselves when it reveals to them
their own lying their own deception
that's going on and so you know
this is quite interesting what he's
saying there
is you can't truly enjoy the happy life
until you get these things straightened
out these priorities properly
reestablished and that requires
placing god at the apex or at the the
center of things so this is augustine's
examination of the happy life within
the human capacity of memory
you